Eve?
Eve, where are you?
Yes, Hunter.
I'm right here.
Is everything okay?
I'm trying to stay calm, but I think I'm stuck.
The snow is so deep, I can't wiggle my way out.
Well, you're doing a great job keeping calm.
Let's take a breath and figure this out.
Now, do you know how to get help when you need it?
How do I do that?
Well, when you recognize you need help,...
...think about a safe person who might help you.
Can you help me, Eve?
I would love to help you, Hunter,...
...but I'm afraid I'm not strong enough to fly you out of there.
Any other ideas?
Hey, there's Mr. Garcia.
He's my next door neighbor and is really nice.
Plus, he's really strong.
What should I say?
Ask for help by explaining what you are trying to do or what you need.
Okay, but what if he says no or he can't help?
It never hurts to ask.
Just be polite.
You will be surprised how often others are willing to help you.
Excuse me, Mr. Garcia.
Hey, little buddy.
What's up?
I think I'm stuck.
Would you mind pulling me out?
Sure, no problem.
Hold still.
Hunter, do you know what step three is?
I bet I can guess.
Step three is to say thanks for the help you receive.
Thank you, Mr. Garcia.
Very good.
I couldn't have said it better myself.